these are images of the last time elena
burden says she saw her sister tatyana
kalushna at the polish ukrainian border
burden traveled from her home in calgary
to meet kalushna there she only saw her
sister for a few minutes before she
turned around and crossed the border
again she kissed kids
hug them
and walk away and she said i can give
you my kids hand to hand
because i trust you you can take care
about them
but
i will go back to ukraine kalushna
returned to riviera in southern ukraine
to be with her husband burden says her
sister is prepared to pick up a gun and
defend her home i could say nothing to
her you know it's it's no begging it's
um you know like i've tried i've tried
especially when she was here in poland
safe i'll reading
why why stay here i will take care about
you and i will take care about the kids
children don't don't don't tell me don't
don't say me anything i've made my
decision burton remains at a hotel in
warsaw with her eight and ten-year-old
nephew and niece sister-in-law jana
kalushna and her daughter on ashram
she says jana is devastated to leave
behind her husband his advice to stay
strong and look out for their little
girl the child is the most important
so think about phone don't think about
me burton reluctantly accepts her
sister's decision admitting she would do
the same her focus now is on the
children who have been told they're
going on a vacation to canada all what
they can do is to save the kids
and give them a life
without uh bomb shelters without air
sirens you know burton hopes to be back
in calgary by the end of the week i want
to give them
those kids some better life normal kids
life so they can forget about this at
least a little bit carol and curry de
castillo global news